now to more breaking developments
surrounding the fbi raid at mar-a-lago
now at the time of the raid the biden
white house remember they claimed they
had no prior knowledge at all of the
investigation and they were learning
about it for the first time on the news
like everybody else but last night right
here on this program investigative
reporter john solomon told us all of
that is just simply not true and based
on documents reviewed by solomon the
biden white house in fact actually
facilitated the doj's probe against
donald trump one high-level biden
staffer was even in communication with
the fbi and the doj as early as april
the 15th and conveyed quote president
joe biden would not object to waving his
predecessor's claims to executive
privilege in other words the byte
administration was actively paving the
way for the fbi's investigation into
documents from trump's time as president
that trump had every legal right to
possess as the wall street journal and
our own greg jarrett pointed out federal
law gives mr trump a right of access to
them his possession of them is entirely
consistent with that right and therefore
lawful regardless of the statutes that
the fbi is citing in their warrant in
other words there was no legal basis for
this unprecedented warrant now keep in
mind top democrats have always been
treated with you know kid gloves by the
fbi and the doj when accused of any
official misconduct there was no raid of
hillary clinton's house after she put
our country at risk by storing top
secret and classified material on not
one but multiple private servers that
were likely hacked our own government
beliefs by foreign governments in fact
in july of 2016 after listing all the
classified material that was mishandled
james comey declared that no prosecutor
would ever bring charges against hillary
clinton prior to an election don't
remember we'll remind you take a look
110 emails
in 52 email chains have been determined
by the owning agency to contain
classified information
at the time they were sent or received
eight of those chains contained
information that was top secret at the
time they were sent
36 of those chains contained secret
information at the time
and eight contained confidential
information at the time although we did
not find clear evidence that secretary
clinton or her colleagues intended to
violate laws governing the handling of
classified information there is evidence
that they were extremely careless
in their handling of very sensitive
highly classified information although
there is evidence of potential
violations of the statutes regarding the
handling of classified information our
judgment is that no reasonable
prosecutor would bring such a case
now she was a secretary of state donald
trump was a president with the right to
declassify anything he wanted at any
time there was no raid there was no
search warrant no charges against
hillary clinton there was also no raid
of sandy berger's house remember he went
into the national archives and he stole
classified material from those archives
remember he stuffed it into his pants
his underwear and his socks no raid on
any of the homes belonging to joe or
hunter biden despite verified evidence
of serious criminal misconduct from
hunter's laptop from hell and yet the
fbi the doj has no problem raiding the
house of biden's possible future
political opponent and that's former
president donald trump even though in
june trump met with the doj officials
and the fbi officials at mar-a-lago and
by the way they were offered then to
access any documents they wanted they
were invited back to get anything that
they needed and they even put the
padlock on the document storage room
because the the doj and the fbi
requested it so they cooperated fully
and by the way we have a letter from the
national archives and records uh group
themselves saying that yeah that
department cooperated fully with the
trump people and they were very helpful
the whole investigation as we've said
from day one it wreaks a political bias
it is a shocking abuse of power it is
unequal application of our laws at its
very worst and the investigation is from
the same exact group the same people the
same fbi officials that elevated the
russia hoax and the mueller witch hunt
now according to congressman jim jordan
fbi whistleblowers they're now coming
forward every other week with
allegations of political bias and
corruption now the question tonight is
where do we go from here hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else